have you ever trodden on a lego brick in
your bare feet
you're tiptoeing through your lounge
late at night and suddenly that stabbing
pain
the expletives and the inevitable
question
why do we have so much of this stuff all
over the place well that's really quite
simple your kids love playing with it
so you buy more
and a confession i love to watch my kids
play with
lego especially good is when i see them
inventing their own rules and their own
worlds
so here are my daughters last saturday
making something out of different kits
and pieces of string and pieces of wood
and dolls and other objects i asked them
what is it and they said to me dad of
course it's a princess flying on a
dragon to visit farm animals in new york
of course what else could it be
kids at play inspire me they're not
afraid to ask
what if and why not
but what kids implicitly know that
adults tend to forget
is that play isn't just about fun
now as a biologist i know that play is
spontaneous and pleasurable as you can
see by the smiles in this photograph but
also
it accelerates and de-risks learning
it helps kids to try out new behaviors
to refine those behaviors and to imagine
what is not but what could be or what
will be
as a business strategist dealing with
adults i still recommend play in fact
play in business is not just possible
i'd argue that it's essential and even
urgent and here's why
competitive advantage fades away faster
than any time in recent memory in the
1980s if you had a performance edge over
your competitors you could reasonably
expect to continue being a leader for
around 10 years on average
but now the half-life of that advantage
a shrunk to just one year
that means that short-lived success is
actually still very common
but sustained success becomes very hard
and very rare
that means that actually reimagination
is the new execution
in order to stay on top or even just to
tread water and stay still
you need to constantly re-imagine your
business but that's not so simple if you
already have a highly successful
business model
we become prisoners of the mental models
that underpin our past success
in fact i found in dealing with
businesses that you can't really stretch
your strategy
unless you stretch your mind
now play is of course a great way of
stretching your mind now
let me there be no mistake i'm not
suggesting literally that executives
huddle around the conference table
with a big pile of lego bricks although
i've done that and that works too
but instead
i've created a series of imagination
games to help executives to stretch
their thinking
would you like to play with me
good i'm glad you said that
okay so
let's supposing that you're stuck in the
rut of seeing the world through the lens
of your past and current success
i would recommend the anti-company game
and here's how it works
you get a piece of paper you create a
list of everything which is essential to
your strategy everything which underpin
your past success
everything which is core and sacred
and then you flip it
you create the exact mirror image list
of assumptions
and then you make the best business case
for this anti-self
you'll be surprised at the ideas that it
triggers
supposing for example that you're the
ceo of a hotel chain
and playing the game and flipping the
assumptions
let's assume that inconveniently you
don't actually own any hotels
or any rooms or even operate any hotels
or any rooms anywhere
ridiculous
quite possibly
but actually how would you know the
difference between ridiculous and merely
unfamiliar untried and uncomfortable
and who's to say that something that
seems impractical can't actually become
and evolve into a more powerful idea
actually had the executives
of hotels played the anti-company game
before 2007
they might have been able to foresee the
appearance of airbnb
the hotelless hospitality company and
they might have been able to stave off
disruption
by preemptively disrupting themselves
let's play another game
the maverick game
on the edge of your industries on the
edge of every industry are a population
of maverick companies that are taking a
bet
against the incumbent's business model
and their view of the future
actually they have no choice because to
be a miniature version of the incumbent
would not be viable
now it's easy not to notice that many of
them are small companies
it's easy to deliberately overlook them
with some justification many startups
disappear fairly quickly after being
founded
and it's very very tempting given all of
your experience in the business
to judge them
do they know what they're doing does
their business model make sense will
they ever make any money
but instead of judging them from the
comfort and the confidence of your
position
try assuming that it's they that have
the right bet on the future
think about the consequences of that for
your business model
try making the best case
for their idea
suppose for example that you are the ceo
of a company
that makes equipment that makes
semiconductors
naturally you'd probably spend most of
your time and attention on your main
customer industry the electronics
industry
and if it so happened
the couple of maverick bioscience
companies were tinkering with your
patents and your technologies you might
overlook that as a distraction and
irrelevance
but actually brooks automation a leader
in the field
decided to take a close-up look at such
a group of mavericks to see whether it
could learn anything
and what it realized by looking at the
world through the the eyes of these
mavericks was that actually the same
techniques and technologies which can be
used to handle delicate semiconductors
can also be applied to other fragile and
easily contaminated materials like
biological samples
and puzzling on the significance of this
they reimagined how to handle and store
and transport and label and identify
biological samples
in fact they became
a successful pioneer in the new industry
of automated biobanking
so successful in fact that just a couple
of days ago they announced that this was
now their core business moving forwards
it's only by focusing on these anomalous
mavericks that they could see their own
path to renewed success and growth
now not everything in business goes
according to plan
in fact sometimes the plans go horribly
awry
but you know what that can be a source
of inspiration too
to find out how
let's play the
pre-mortem game
so your role in this game
is to write
the obituary for your company
which is going to fail
with 100 certainty in five years time
what is the cause of death
what will have been the point of failure
why will it have failed how will it have
failed
the challenge here is that it's easy to
be seduced into the baseline fallacy the
baseline fallacies the idea that it's
the current business model which is the
low-risk bet
and of course that tends to be true
until it isn't true
at which point it's probably too late to
do anything about it
now your employees are an early warning
indicator they will have intuitions if
the model begins to slip but it's very
hard for them to speak up and it's even
taboo for them to speak up
when the business model is under
pressure
but when executives create playgrounds
spaces for the safe exploration of
alternatives and alternative scenarios
then you get to tap into your employees
considerable experience about the
vulnerabilities and the weak spots and
the blind spots of your company
does anyone remember visiting recently
one of these gorgeous marble palaces
no it's probably been a while since we
visited the local banking branch
had bricks and mortar banks played the
premortem game
perhaps they would have heard their
employees
expressing some concerns about the
gradually dwindling flow of customers to
local branches
and perhaps they would have been
slightly less taken by surprise when
companies like newbank a digital native
seized very rapidly indeed on that
opportunity
to convince to date more than 40 million
latin americans
that in-person transactions in real
buildings were a quaint but obsolete
relic of the past
it's only when you bring your
vulnerabilities into full view in this
way that you may be motivated to
reimagine your business and to do so in
a robust manner
it's why the roman catholic church
invented the role the position of the
devil's advocate in the 16th century
to test the future consequences of its
decisions to appoint new saints
they did that by imagining
what would satan say
or propose or counter-propose in
addition to the normal procedure
of thinking about the big man upstairs
now any human being any employee any
team and therefore any company can
harness human imagination it's a
defining trait of our species
failures to imagine in business are
really failures of leadership
business is a serious matter but it
should not exclude play
when leaders embrace play and imagine
imagination games they can unlock the
imagination of their employees
uncover disruptive new strategies and
renew their lease on the future thank
you
[Applause]